en este vídeo quiero darte un panorama
acerca de los cuadriláteros aquí tenemos
el prefijo cuadri vaya a la palabra
empieza con cuadri y eso tiene que ver
con cuatro y además dice lateros que
tiene que ver con la dos y justo a los
cuadriláteros son figuras en el plano
que tienen cuatro lados por ejemplo este
de aquí sería un cuadrilátero este de
aquí sería un cuadrilátero también este
de acá es un cuadrilátero y otra figura
un poco más alargada como de este estilo
también es un cuadrilátero vale estos de
aquí son tres cuadriláteros y los
cuadriláteros además de tener cuatro
lados tienen cuatro vértices cuatro
vértices
y cuatro ángulos este este este y este
el del medio es un ejemplo interesante
así que déjame pintarlo por acá un poco
más grande algo así más o menos algo así
ok está en los cuatro lados uno dos tres
cuatro los cuatro vértices y los cuatro
ángulos 12 hay tres chiquitos y uno
grande entonces puede verse un poco raro
pero definitivamente es un cuadrilátero
bueno nos interesa clasificar los
cuadriláteros en varios tipos y la
primera gran clasificación que vamos a
hacer es en cuadriláteros cóncavos
cóncavos
y en cuadriláteros convexos convexos
y para recordarlo bueno al menos yo lo
hago así para recordar cuáles son los
cuadriláteros cóncavos pues son aquellos
que tienen como una pequeña cueva en uno
de sus lados o sea como que tenemos dos
lados y los otros dos hacen una pequeña
cueva más o menos así es como este que
dibujé oeste de aquí abajo oeste vale y
una forma de decir esto formalmente una
forma de definirlos es que son aquellos
cuadriláteros en los cuales algunos de
los ángulos miden más de 180 grados
entonces este ángulo de acá mide más de
180 grados muy bien una cosa importante
que a lo mejor demuestra en otro vídeo
es que si tenemos un cuadrilátero
cóncavo entonces es imposible que un par
de sus lados sea paralelo vale no pueden
tener lados paralelos
ok bueno con eso en mente que a lo mejor
después demostremos vamos a pasar ahora
a los cuadriláteros convexos los
cuadriláteros convexos a diferencia de
los cóncavos tienen todos sus ángulos
menores a 180 grados por ejemplo este de
aquí este de aquí sería un cuadrilátero
convexo porque todos los ángulos todos
son menores a 180 grados este de aquí
también es convexo y este de acá también
es convexo y mira o sea a lo mejor te
puedes preguntar qué sucede si uno de
los ángulos es igual a 180 grados pero
si sucede eso entonces tendríamos un
vértice otro y otro y entonces estos en
realidad tendrían una línea recta y en
vez de ser dos lados sólo sería uno así
que nuestro supuesto cuadrilátero en
realidad es un triángulo vale entonces
no nos va a interesar esos cuadriláteros
o sean esos no queremos que sean
cuadriláteros vale bueno entonces los
convexos en los convexos todos los
ángulos son menores a 180 grados y
dentro de los conversos vamos a tener
otra clasificación otra sub
clasificación déjame déjame separar aquí
con color verde entonces aquí voy a
poner una división y ya nada más vamos a
platicar de puros cuadriláteros convexos
vale el primer tipo de cuadriláteros
convexos que nos interesa y lo voy a
poner un poco más a la izquierda y por
acá son los trapecios los trapecios
a pesos la definición todavía está un
poquito en debate hay una definición un
poco rígida que dice que exactamente un
par de lados tiene que ser paralelo por
ejemplo si tenemos un cuadrilátero algo
así es más dejan poner un poquito más
checo algo así y luego viene por acá y
luego viene por acá entonces esto de
aquí sería un trapecio porque la forma
en la cual lo dibujé fue que este lado
sea paralelo a este lado o sea hacia
aquí se llama a este vértice b este c y
éste lo pinté de tal forma que ave ave
el segmento ave es paralelo al segmento
cede y eso justo quiere decir eso justo
quiere decir que esto es un trapecio
la letrada precio y la otra definición
que es un poquito más flexible nos dice
que al menos un par de lados sea
paralelo entonces la otra definición
permitiría que algo como esto algo como
esta figura también sea un trapecio una
figura en la cual este lado es paralelo
a éste
este lado es paralelo a este vale
entonces hay dos definiciones la que se
usa más es la estricta en donde
exactamente un par de lados es paralelo
pero a lo mejor te encuentres con que en
algunos lugares pidan que al menos un
par de lados sea paralelo vale entonces
con la definición más estricta este sí
es trapecio pero este no pero no hay que
preocuparnos porque esta figura también
tiene un nombre especial una figura en
la cual los dos pares de lado son
paralelos o sea los lados opuestos son
paralelos se conoce como paralelogramo
lo voy a poner por acá paralelogramo
un gramo
vale bueno estoy acá definitivamente es
un trapecio esto a veces es un trapecio
o no dependiendo de la definición pero
definitivamente es un paralelogramo y
justo a la idea es que estés paralelo a
este y este es paralelo a este muy bien
pero dentro de los paralelo gramos hay
algunos paralelo gramos especiales
hay algunos paralelo gramos que tienen
sus cuatro ángulos iguales y otros que
tienen sus cuatro lados iguales y esos
también nos van a interesar observa que
los cuadriláteros bueno ya lo platicamos
en un vídeo anterior en un cuadrilátero
la suma de los ángulos es de 360 grados
así que si todos los ángulos son iguales
tienen que ser iguales a 90 y bueno los
ángulos de 90 grados se llaman ángulos
rectos así que los paralelo gramos en
los cuales los cuatro ángulos son
iguales se conocen como rectángulos y
puede ponerlo por acá en color verde
entonces aquí voy a poner a los
rectángulos
directa
muy bien entonces como te decía los
cuatro ángulos son iguales y por lo
tanto deben de ser iguales a 90 grados
y hay además otro tipo de paralelo
gramos especiales en donde los cuatro
lados son iguales y esos se conocen como
rombos lo voy a poner aquí rooms
rombos vale entonces aquí lo único que
pedimos es que los cuatro lados los
cuatro lados sean iguales de este este
este y este son iguales muy bien déjame
trazar unos circuitos para que para
decirte cómo es cómo están las familias
entonces todo esto hay acá todo esto de
acaso un paralelogramo lo voy a poner
hasta acá todo esto de acaso un
paralelogramo vale entonces cualquier
rectángulo tiene los lados opuestos
paralelos cualquier rombo también pero
si tenemos un paralelogramo no tiene por
qué ser rectángulo ni ser rombo por
ejemplo este que dibuje aquí pues no
aparece ni rectángulo ni rombo vale
bueno pero los rectángulos y rombos y
son paralelogramo si eso se puede
demostrar
bueno eso lo haremos en otro vídeo pero
por el momento hay una última idea que
me gustaría decirte y es que hay algunos
cuadriláteros que son rectángulos y que
son rombos o sea que tienen sus cuatro
ángulos iguales y sus cuatro lados
iguales así que si tenemos de este lado
a ángulos esta es la familia de los
rectángulos aquí viven todos los
rectángulos y acá tenemos los rombos hay
un tipo de cuadrilátero especial que
vive en la intersección que vive en las
dos familias y seguramente lo conoces
tiene sus cuatro lados iguales
tiene sus cuatro ángulos iguales iguales
a 90 grados y se conoce como cuadrado y
posiblemente sea de las primeras figuras
geométricas que conociste cuadrado muy
bien entonces los cuadrados son
rectángulos los cuadrados son rombos
bayas se pueden pensar cómo rectángulos
o se puede empezar como rombos y también
se puede empezar como paralelogramo
socom o cuadriláteros sin embargo pues
no todos los rectángulos son cuadrados
no todos los rombos son cuadrados y por
supuesto no todos los paralelogramo son
cuadrados este de aquí definitivamente
no es un cuadrado verdad bueno le voy a
dejar hasta aquí a la clasificación este
vídeo era para darte pues una pequeña
digamos taxonomía de los cuadriláteros
para que sepamos de qué estamos hablando
pero en los siguientes vídeos ya vamos a
empezar a ver algunos ejemplos más
interesantes y a descubrir algunas
propiedades de todos estos cuadriláteros
nos vemos en los siguientes vídeos